Imaginez, vous êtes chez vous et vous recevez un colis.
A l’intérieur de ce colis se trouve une boite.
Une boite, comme ça arrive souvent.
Sauf qu'à l’intérieur de la boite,
il y a une information très très spéciale.
Cette information là, il n'y a que vous qui pouvez la connaître
Donc vous ouvrez la boite, vous la posez,
et à l’intérieur de la boite, vous vous apercevez
que vous pouvez ranger le colis.
Le colis, dans la boite que vous avez reçue.
C'est quelque chose de complètement impossible.
Et ça, c'est peut-être l'indication que vous êtes dans un rêve !
Et justement, aujourd'hui, on va parler des rêves lucides.
Un rêve lucide, comme vous l'avez sûrement compris,
c'est un rêve où le rêveur a conscience qu'il est en train de rêver.
Ça veut pas forcément dire qu'il maitrise son rêve,
mais ça veut dire qu'il a conscience du moment qu'il est en train de vivre,
que c'est un rêve, que c'est un monde onirique.
Un des précurseurs en la matière qui fait encore aujourd'hui office de référence
puisqu'il fait encore des conférences là-dessus,
il publie des livres là-dessus, c'est Stéphane LaBerge
qui en 1980 a amené tout un processus scientifique
pour pouvoir vérifier et analyser que des personnes étaient en état de rêve lucide
et pour pouvoir amener aussi tout une méthodologie
pour accéder aux rêves lucides facilement.
Vous rêvez et je rêve dans le sommeil paradoxal.
C'est le moment où on rêve. On rêve une dizaine de fois par nuit.
Un bon rêveur est capable de se souvenir de 4 à 5 de ses rêves,
et bien souvent on ne se souviens d'aucun rêve parce qu'on ne fait pas l'effort de s'en rappeler.
Le rêve lucide donc peut être subi mais peut être aussi contrôlé à plus ou moins grand degré.
Par exemple, moi quand je fais un rêve lucide, j'arrive à contrôler mes actions, ce que je vais faire
mais pas forcément quelles sont les personnes qui vont intervenir,
ou quelles vont être leurs réactions, ou dans quel décor je me trouve.
Je sais qu'il y en a qui arrive à ça mais c'est plus compliqué.
C'est juste histoire de dire que tout n'est pas forcément contrôlable en rêve lucide
et tout n'est pas forcément non plus subi.
L'intérêt du rêve lucide, c'est encore plus qu'un kiff.
Ça permet au sens propre de réaliser ses rêves.
Ça permet de rentrer directement en contact avec son inconscient.
C'est presque comme un sport, ça demande un petit peu d'entraînement.
Je vais vous donner 3 astuces de Stéphane LaBerge et de ses équipes,
qui permettent de rentrer plus facilement dans un état de rêve lucide et volontairement,
et une astuce qui m'est plus personnelle
que j'ai pas retrouvée ailleurs pour le moment.
Première astuce, il faut être capable de vérifier dans un rêve qu'on est en train de rêver.
Pour ça, il faut prendre le pli de le faire également quand on est dans la réalité.
Y a plein plein de techniques qui existent,
par exemple faire sonner un réveil toutes les 2 ou 3 heures, dans la réalité je parle,
et à ce moment là interpréter les signes autour de soi pour voir si on est en train de rêver ou pas.
Je m'étais dit plutôt que de faire sonner un réveil qui ne sonnerait en plus pas dans mon rêve,
je vais prendre un objet récurrent.
Et qu'est ce que je regarde le plus dans une journée ? Mon téléphone.
Du coup, à chaque fois que je regardais mon téléphone,
j'essayais d'analyser si j'étais en train de rêver ou pas.
Mais après je me suis rendu compte de quelque chose :
c'est que dans mes rêves ... j'ai jamais mon téléphone.
Apparemment, je ne téléphone pas dans mes rêves.
Donc j'ai fait l'inverse : j'ai analysé mes rêves pour voir ce que je faisais souvent
et alors va savoir pourquoi moi souvent dans mes rêves, je rentre chez moi.
Une de mes récurrences, je rentre chez moi mais mon chez moi peut être de mille formes différentes :
ça peut être une toile de tente, ça peut être un palais, mais je rentre chez moi.
Donc maintenant, à chaque fois que j'ouvre la porte de chez moi,
à chaque fois que je rentre chez moi dans la réalité,
je me demande d'où je viens : est ce que je sais exactement d'où je viens et comment je suis arrivé ici,
je regarde l'heure, je tourne la tête et je re-regarde l'heure et je vérifie si l'heure s'écoule normalement
et j'essaie de comprendre quel moment de la journée on est
pour voir si tout est cohérent et si je sais ce que je vais faire après.
Et le fait de faire ça dans la réalité à chaque fois que j'ouvre la porte de chez moi,
ça fait que quand j'entre dans un rêve
et que je rentre chez moi en rêve,
parfois, c'est pas tout le temps, parfois, le même réflexe se remet en place.
Autant vous dire que la 1ère fois que ça s'est fait, je me suis réveillé, pas de panique mais plutôt d'excitation en fait.
J'étais en train de prendre conscience que je rêvais.
Et c'est vraiment pas à chaque fois en fait.
On dit qu'un bon rêveur lucide,
ça va lui arriver 4 à 5 fois dans le mois.
C'est quand même quelque chose d'assez rare.
Une deuxième bonne astuce, c'est le soir, quand vous vous endormez,
vous décidez que vous allez faire un rêve lucide.
Vous vous détendez bien dans le lit, vous vous dites une phrase du genre :
"Ce soir, je vais prendre conscience que je rêve."
Le fait de le verbaliser, c'est un message très fort que vous envoyez à votre inconscient.
Et le 3ème astuce, c'est celle de jubjoter.
Alors jubjoter, c'est un mot qui n'existe pas, quand même !
C'est un mot qui a été inventé en fait.
C'est le fait de retourner dans ses rêves.
Vous êtes un peu comateux et puis vous replongez un petit peu dans le rêve : c'est ça jubjoter.
Donc essayez quand vous vous réveillez et que vous n'avez pas à vous lever,
de bien vous remémorer le rêve, de vous remettre dedans
mais de commencer à essayer de décider des actions que vous allez y faire avant d'y replonger.
Et d'une manière générale, essayez de vous rappeler de vos rêves.
C'est-à-dire que quand vous vous réveillez le matin,
prenez une à deux minutes vraiment dans le lit,
pour essayer de consolider comme ça tous vos souvenirs de rêves.
Ne laissez pas le brouillard se dissiper.
Plus vous allez prêtez d'attention à vos rêves, plus vous allez facilement faire des rêves lucides.
Et la dernière technique que j'ai trouvée qui fonctionne bien sur moi.
Quand je rêve, je me vois souvent comme si je me filmais on va dire,
je me vois depuis l'extérieur et j'assiste aux scènes.
Je sais pas si c'est votre cas ?  Dites le moi dans les commentaires d'ailleurs,
ça m'intéresserait de voir si je suis le seul mec chelou comme ça !
Donc dans le lit le soir, quand je m'amuse à imaginer les rêves que je pourrais faire
ou que je me rappelle les rêves que je faisais,
j'essaie vraiment de m'imaginer où je me vois à la première personne comme dans la vie normale.
C'est-à-dire je vois mes 2 bras, je vois mes 2 mains,
je vois mes jambes, je vois mes pieds : je me vois à l'intérieur de mon corps.
Et je crois que c'est ce qui m'a aidé le plus à faire des rêves lucides.
Si ça vous intéresse et que vous voulez aller plus loin que ça,
il y a des formations en onirologie ou des formations en rêve lucide,
des stages en général ça dure 4 ou 5 jours.
Je vous mets également dans le descriptif de la vidéo un excellent site qui s'appelle Attrape-songes.
Y a un des derniers livres de Bernard Werber qui en parle qui s'appelle le 6ème sommeil
qui est un très très bon roman.
Je ne saurais que trop vous recommander aussi le livre de Stéphane LaBerge
qui est à l'origine de tout le travail sur le rêve lucide
en Europe parce que c'est quelque chose qui est très très connu en fait dans d'autres civilisations
mais chez nous, scientifiquement parlant, c'est lui la source.
Il a écrit plein de livres, il donne encore vraiment beaucoup de conférences,
mais pour moi le plus intéressant, c'est celui qu'il a écrit, ça s'appelle "s'éveiller en rêvant" : je vous le mets aussi !
Et, un de mes livres préférés sur le sujet parce qu'il est très très complet
et on sent vraiment que l'auteur à l'habitude
et que c'est pas un ramassis d'informations glanées mais un vrai ressenti
c'est le "guide des rêves lucides, prenez le contrôle de vos rêves"
que je vous mets également dans le package du descriptif.
Merci d'avoir regardé ce Master Class un petit peu différent, j'espère qu'il vous aura plu.
Si c'est le cas, faites le moi savoir en laissant un petit pouce en l'air.
Et puis je le mérite ce pouce en l'air, parce que vous savez quoi ?
Parce qu'on est samedi matin et que je me suis couché tard hier soir,
j'ai bossé toute la semaine et je me suis levé pour faire la vidéo aujourd'hui
et je voulais qu'elle soit de qualité, oui Monsieur !
Et je le prouve puisque je suis encore au café !
Je pense d'ailleurs que j'ai beaucoup moins d'énergie que d'habitude dans cette vidéo !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
en cliquant sur le petit logo qui est en haut à droite ou sous la vidéo.
Et rendez-vous demain à 11h pour le prochain Mental Vlog. Ciao !